great
um so today I'm going to be talking
about visualizing the environmental
impact of beef consumption using plotly
and shiny
hence the shine bright like a diamond
intro song so I am an assistant
professor of biostatistics at Weill
Cornell Medicine this is my twitter
handle so if you want to tweet or follow
me on twitter you can do it there and
great
so to give to start out i wanted to give
a little bit of background about myself
so what I've been up to
and what I've been working on so these
are a couple of places that I've worked
once I finished my graduate training I
wanted to see what it would be like to
be an industry data scientist so I went
and worked out Flatiron help where I did
cancer research using electronic medical
records data I also worked at a small
start-up called Cove era health where I
did evaluations of different radiology
interventions using claims data and then
I really missed academics so I think
that's maybe not a story people hear
that often of going to industry and like
really missing academics and wanting to
come back so just recently about six
months ago I started as an assistant
professor at Weill Cornell Medicine so
if anybody's interested in the path back
to academia from industry I'd be happy
to talk to you about it and give you
some some advice from from my journeys
and so what I normally work on and when
I gave my New York our conference talk
on which you can see online is brain
imaging data so I work a lot on
structural MRI data and some of the
problems that I work on right here I
have a structural MRI from a brain from
a person who has multiple sclerosis this
is an axial slice of the brain and you
can see there are these bright areas on
the image and those are multiple
sclerosis lesions so a lot of my work is
training different algorithms to find
these lesions and to locate those
automatically to help diagnose the
disease and monitor disease progression
I also work a lot on something called
super resolution so right here on the
right side I have a low resolution image
of the brain and I use that to predict
higher resolution
the brain so that you can see more
anatomical detail of what's going on but
today I'm not going to talk about any of
that stuff
I'm actually going to talk about meat so
this is a side project that I've been
working on and it's a collaboration with
the Happy Valley Meat Company so this is
a client that came to me and had a data
problem that they wanted to work on it's
a little bit of a weird data problem for
me to work on because I'm actually a
vegetarian so I don't eat meat at all
but actually the take-home message kind
of guys well with my vegetarianism so
what happen Valley Meat Company does is
they basically go and they work with
different farms and they go to farms
that have very high welfare standards so
they treat animals really well they give
animals a great life and then they take
that meat from those animals who have
been raised well and sell it to
different restaurants in New York City
and their mission is to better the lives
of the people and the animals that feed
us and so how many people are there some
New Yorkers here ok so we've got a few
New Yorkers so some of the like famous
restaurants that Happy Valley meet come
with Jeanne works for our mama fufu you
guys know mama CooCoo so that one's like
super famous dig in they do like the
meatballs that dig in so those are like
ethically made meatballs so you can like
eat those and feel good about yourself
that's a French Chet there's like this
huge list of restaurants I just picked
like some of my favorite ones and so the
big problem that happy Valley Meat
Company faces is that they buy whole
animals so they will buy an entire beef
animal and they need to find homes for
every single part of that animal so
there's very few of those steaks that
you're going to eat at mama fuku on a
single animal and there's a ton of
ground beef so you just get tons and
tons of ground beef and some other cuts
but they have to find a home for all of
that
and so what one of the things that they
tried to do to do this was to quantify
the environmental impact that each cut
of meat has so if it takes one cow to
make 250 pounds of ground beef we can
quantify the environmental impact of one
cow if it takes 200
50 cows to get 250 pounds of a smaller
cut of steak we can quantify the
environmental impact of that and so
that's where I came in to start
quantifying that impact and to make
visualizations of this that we could
give to restaurants to help them make
better informed decisions about which
meat they were buying and so the data
that I got when I went to work on this
project was this so normally I'm used to
getting like tons and tons of like brain
imaging data but I got this is just the
head of the data but I just got a very
small amount of data so I got whatever
cut on the animal and how much the total
weight for that cut was on the animal so
right here I have ground beef 250 pounds
bone and stripped 36 pounds so I have
just the amount of what cut of meat and
the amount of weight on a cow that we
have for that cut of meat and so I
started out by plotting this and so I
made a bar plot so I think somebody was
saying earlier this is their favorite
kind of plot d Rob it's my favorite kind
of plot too so and you'll see I made
like 10 of these so like it's really my
favorite plot so this is the weight of
each cut per animal and so you can see
you get tons and tons of ground beef on
one animal but things like hanger steak
tongue or ox tail you don't get as much
and so that's like the first way that I
conceptualize this and then I just
wanted to zoom in on a couple of like
common cuts so ground beef bone-in
ribeye tenderloin skirt and tongue I
guess tongues not that common but
there's like very little tongue on there
so I'm using it as an example okay so
the next part was to quantify the
environmental impact that each one of
these cuts had so what I did was I
looked up how much water a single cow
used during its lifetime so a single Cal
uses six point three six million gallons
of water throughout its lifetime so
that's quite a bit of water the really
bad thing about cows and and eating them
is they have extremely high co2
emissions so one single
emits 1,000 2,000 pounds of carbon
emissions during their lifetime and then
they use about 77 acres of land and so
the where I got this information was the
shifting diets for a sustainable food
future so you can check that out where
these constants came from and so the
next thing I need to figure out was if I
had a certain amount of weight or a cut
of meat how many cows that would use so
I have I'm going to start with a hundred
pounds of whatever products so this is a
hundred pounds of ground beef 100 pounds
of hanger steak and calculate how many
cows that requires so these are the
calculations that I did and so if I need
a hundred pounds of ground beef that
would be one cow a hundred pounds of
bone-in strip I would need three cows to
come up with that and then what I did
was I took the number of cows and
multiplied it by how much the
environmental impact was for each one of
or for each cut so now what I've got
I've got the cut of meat the number of
cows required the millions of gallons of
water the thousands of pounds of co2
emissions and the acres of land and so
the next thing I did was I made another
bar plot so all this data I'm going to
be making tons and tons of bar plots
I like how many people use the West
Anderson color library yeah I'm a huge
fan I love Wes Anderson movies and like
I'm I think I'm like late to the game on
this one cuz I just found it last year
and I think it's been like out there for
a long time but so I use the West
Anderson palette with the DAR Julian
color palette but yeah so I'm just
making another bar plot and so here we
can see the environmental impact for
eating a hundred pounds of meat by cut
so you can see that if you ate a hundred
pounds or if you bought as a restaurant
a hundred pounds of tongue that would be
over 80 animals so that would have a
larger environment
impact then if you bought a hundred
pounds of ground beef that would be only
about one cow
I made a word chart it didn't show up as
well in here but just the size of each
one of the words and the word cloud
represents how many animal lives is
taken for each one of those cuts for a
hundred pounds of it okay
I found this function so I wanted to
share it with you guys I don't does
anybody know the name of this it's the %
+ % ok I don't know what the name of it
is so if anybody knows please come up
after like I've done and tell me what
the name of this is but it allows you to
replace a data frame that you're using
with ggplot so basically what I can do
is if I have that bar plot where I'm
plotting it for all the different cuts
of meat but I want to filter that down
and only plot it for four cuts of meat I
don't have to redo all of my code I can
just say plot that out whatever the name
of this function is filter plot data
cuts in a particular cut list and this
is like my new favorite function I found
it like a couple months ago so I wanted
to share it with everybody and this
makes a smaller plot of of these
particular cuts so my talk is on plot Li
one of the really convenient things is
if you are making a GG plot you can make
it a plot way plot with just one command
so if I use the library plot Li and I
use the function GG plot Li take my plot
and just put it in here I get oh we got
small all right imagine this a little
bit bigger
I've whenever I project things they
change but now I have this thing that I
can that I can kind of click on and
hover over the bars and I can see the
exact number of cows that each cut of
meat takes so if I look at round that
takes two cows to make a hundred pounds
of beef or if I look at oxtail that
takes 67 cows so now I've made this into
an interactive plot with just one
command
ggplot Lee so it's very powerful I use
this all the time and my collaborative
work if I'm making like a scatterplot
and I want my investigator to be able to
find outliers I just take whatever GG
plot plot I made wrap GG plot lay around
it and then people can investigate it
automatically so very very powerful so
we can do this for those select things
and then we can do co2 emissions water
usage and land usage so something that
you'll notice is that all of these plots
are like the same plot over and over
again like they're linearly related
the co2 usage the land usage because
it's all based on the number of cows and
a constant so I made this plot but
nobody liked this plot when I was so I
think this plot is great but it was like
beta tested with restaurants and it was
like very unfavorably like no one liked
it but basically what I did is I took
all the different cuts and then I put
four different axes on it so I have
thousands of pounds of carbon emissions
millions of gallons of waters acres of
land and number of lives because I was
like who wants to look at the same four
plots and you know it has the same
information but that got like nixed like
right out the gate
it was beta tested with some restaurants
and nobody liked the four different axes
so I want to talk about and show some
plot lee code for some other projects
that I've been working on so somebody
once joked that I'm only passionate
about two things which are data science
and hiking so this I'm going to share
something from my other passion with you
guys so how many people have ever gone
hiking in the Catskills
a couple people all right so there's
this notorious path in the Catskills
called the devil's path and it's about a
20 mile hike with like 8,500 miles of
elevation gain so there are five
different mountains on the devil's path
and so I wanted to plot this thing which
is kind of a profile of the mountain
in our and I wanted to use plotly so I
could see how far along the trail I'd be
going and what elevation that I would be
at and so this uh this is part of the
Catskills 3500 Club so if you hike all
of the mountains in the Catskills that
are above 3500 feet there's 35 of them
you get like this little badge and it's
like a big deal and I just finished it
this summer so I hiked all of the
mountains in the Catskills yeah I'm very
excited about that it took me two years
of like hiking like all the time to
finish this but yeah so that's part of
the Catskills 3500 Club but so online
there's this research called Cal topo
which will give you latitude longitude
distance and miles elevation and feet
and a couple of other things for almost
any hike in the United States it might
be in other countries as well but this
is data I got from Cal topo and what I'm
going to be interested in for this is
the distance and miles and the elevation
and feet and so this is one where I went
and wrote the code in plotly so I didn't
use ggplot Lee I read this directly
there so you can see it's not like the
syntax from ggplot2 it's a little
crazier you need to kind of like learn a
not crazier but you need to learn like a
difference in tax to plot this but I
have a tutorial on my github about all
of like just using the plot underscore
lis function to to make plots so you can
check that out and it's all hiking
themed so I made like hundreds of like
hiking themed plots using this but you
get something like this so this is the
devil's path along the x-axis I have the
distance and miles along the trail and
the y-axis is the elevation and feet and
so you can follow the trail and you can
go okay like one mile in I am two
thousand two hundred and sixty miles or
scuse me not miles that would be crazy
feet above sea level and then you might
be interested this mountain right here
is called plateau mountain because it
has this like plateau top on it and you
might be cure
like what's the elevation of Plateau my
mountain so you can scroll around and
you can see oh it's about 3,800 feet and
so I think this is a really fun like
interactive plot of like for hiking okay
so the last thing that I want to show
you I promise some shiny okay good the
Internet's working so this is the prot
the data product that I gave to Happy
Valley Meat Company they wanted to call
it I don't know if this name is very
tasteful the carcass calculator I think
like I was like oh if you want I will do
it but let's say we want a thousand
pounds of meat and we're going to get
maybe ground beef I don't even eat meat
so I don't know what's popular
I think boneless New York Strip and
Chuck I so you can click on whatever
cuts of meat you want select how many
pounds of meat you want and it produces
first this table and so this table is a
way that you can compare how many
animals so think of yourself as a
restaurant now and you are deciding
alright I'm going to make my menu and I
want to have a low environmental impact
for this menu so you could say alright
if I buy ground beef that'll be for
animals and like four hundred and eleven
thousand pounds of carbon emissions but
if I did the menu with hanger steak that
would be six hundred and sixty seven
animals and that would be like a ton of
co2 emissions so you can actually make
choices based upon this and then I've
got the co2 emissions for or these bar
plots with the the plotly thing so that
they can visualize it this way but this
is where they didn't like the thing
where I had the different axes which I'm
still stuck on cuz I think like clicking
on each one and it's the same plot but
yeah so this is a tool that Happy Valley
Meat Company actually gives to
restaurants and
restaurants use this to plan their menu
and try and pick the most
environmentally friendly choices that
they can that's appropriate for the
restaurant great well that's why I've
got to show you guys today so thank you
so much
[Applause]